Joshua is in Dallas Texas hi Joshua how
are you how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so basically I am stuck in between
whether I should file for bankruptcy or
just go ahead and start paying all my
debts off that snowball basically all my
debts except my car are in collections
so that's why that's the only reason I'm
basically contemplating bankruptcy why
are they all in collections they're like
old medical bills one is it flow as a
car they got repo'd because of I lost my
job
and I think I think like a phone bill is
in there too okay so how much is the
repo bill that one's actually only like
a couple grams biggest what I have on
there is nine five thousand four hundred
and forty five dollars from an old
apartment
how long ago son three and a half years
ago okay and how much how much how much
much medical data we got I would say
about two thousand and what other that
have you got the rest of it is this
mixed in there with like my fault I
think it's phone bill and all into
payday loans as well yeah so your total
that's less than $20,000 right and then
I have my car which is twelve thousand
okay and what do you make a year a
little bit over forty five I'll make a
thousand a week I'm an independent
contractor mm-hmm and you're single I'm
married you're married all right I am 28
on Saturday there's a happy birthday
does she work outside the home no she
stays at home takes care of her okay
good mm-hm well let me tell you what I'm
hearing
okay and I think I'm hearing maybe I'm
wrong
Larry Burkett used to say that debt is
not the problem it's the symptom of
something else that's going on right and
it sounds like you guys have never told
your money what to do you've never had
any savings for emergencies so every
time an emergency comes up you get
thrown out of an apartment and sued your
car gets repo'd and you end up with a
mess so we've got to get you on a plan
where you are telling your money what to
do or you're gonna be back here if I
waved him on and made all this debt go
away which is what bankruptcy might do
maybe if it did that and made you have a
zero debt all of a sudden except your
car if you don't change the habits that
cause this mess in the first place
you'll be back right where you are
someday do you agree yes you know so we
really need to get under that because
bankruptcy doesn't solve that you've got
to solve that in the mirror you and your
wife learning how to handle money I
don't think you're bankrupt I think
you're scared
disorganized don't know what to do and
have done nothing so far I think you can
probably settle that old apartment that
for three or four grand if you saved it
up and offer them a lump sum settlement
I've actually called them I started
listen to you that wasn't one of the
first videos that I was looking up with
out of it that collectors you know up
from under you it does it doesn't change
my answer to whether it's nine thousand
or three thousand you're still not
bankrupt it's still about you getting
control of your money and when you do
that then you're gonna see your way
through this bankruptcy it's not a debt
problem it's a behavior problem that's
gotten you here I'll help you out I'm
gonna send you copy the Total Money
Makeover book read that take an extra
job sell everything in sight and let's
get this mess cleaned up I'll show you
how to do it
hey keep listening man thank you for
being with us this is the Dave Ramsey
show
[Music]